[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello happy Friday everybody yeah 2 p.m.
theme though it just rolled over right
as we started excellent uh welcome to
this week's community Fridays I'm John
Luke Ben is with me as usual it's me I'm
here and we're just pushes jammin yeah
we are you you've on Logic your
community center and these these musical
gems I unlocked it this morning
so I got all the jams going yeah we're
playing Animal Crossing you're playing
animal crossing with you guys
so John Luke is being so kind as to let
everyone run around on his own ways yep
so basically we're just gonna hang out
it's gonna be a super chill casual
stream right below me I have the dodo
code so hop on in and just come hang out
for a little bit yeah we'll do some
fishing show off some the cool things
that you guys have made so no people
have been going crazy yeah if people
want to show off their outfits if they
want to show off anything cool they have
please do by the way I have had a
surplus of peacock butterflies today so
if you are interested it seems like you
have a pretty good chance of catching
some on my island today they seem to be
all over the place and that's the jam
and that's the jam you make a lot of
money off those things that's that's
what that's the rumor says yeah we got
we got Brandon here we got Persian here
yikes Jake's here Jake's here Jacob of
the the podcast Fame
gamespot after dark if you haven't been
listening or watching you should
probably do that yes
Oh peacock did you've already got one
watch someone's gonna try to try to jump
in right yeah I'm definitely to take
advantage of this today and just get on
these someone's are joining excellent
the one thing I'm a little nervous about
the stream is we're gonna be seeing this
a lot
yeah that's you know that's how it works
though we get a little bit like at like
a fashion runway walk for people as they
come in though hey I'm okay with that so
we get we get they get announced
formally it's
excellent she's coming in let's see what
what fashion she's rocking it's good
yeah thanks SP kind of butterfly is how
we paid off his debts they go so if you
need some money come on over and want to
be in here right now
catch some peacock butterflies you're
trying to join heck yeah join up and
hopefully we'll be able to get kind of
people rotating in and out so they can
kind of experience it mmm
it'll be interesting at the beginning
because everyone's gonna be trying to
like put their codes in and yeah poor
Wilbur is gonna be like I can't do it
how far are you in the game so I'm like
a day behind where you are I think okay
so like everything shut down and we're
rebuilding okay cool yeah it's a bummer
I just paid off my house I was going to
pay it off the day before everything
shut down but I forgot about the and I
was like literally like 1500 or like
15,000 off but that I forgot that at 10
o'clock the store closes and I had no
way to sell all my stuff to get the
remaining amount rising from anime oh
shoot animes here I do appreciate the
the power behind just calling your your
whole Island anime hey it's excellent
what does the pseudo-code because I'm
new so the dodo code it's the code you
put in when you when you go to the
airport and you say hey I want to fly
you've had the option to put in a dodo
code and it's basically like the way
anyone can join as opposed to just
trying to invite only your friends list
the invite stuff is actually pretty good
for a Nintendo game yeah it recognizes
your friend list which is kind of like a
huge right and then life thing once they
join you can make them best friends and
then
it's like easier to know if they're
online and invite them or message on
which is great the only it's just the
the thing the fact that everyone gets
stopped for a sec well I'm getting look
at looking at monokuma type I was about
to say that's really yeah I'm in no way
good evening from the UK good evening J
okay somebody else is on the way here
perfectly this is fine you just will get
it all out right just get it all get it
all do you need cherries I can bring
cherries I actually have my Island is a
cherry Islands so I'm actually those
pears that I dropped I did I got those
look at those those Paris whoops I will
close my window right now
couple minutes it's all good
I do kind of like that it kind of like
has a whole like hello it's this person
and they're here me too I thing is
really cute it's more that it just like
stops new every time is this the Riu say
that I know there was this a different
ryu say that's the question that's
that's what i want to know where my chat
go back so I did harvest all my cherries
this morning but I have them all so if
people want I can I can give out some
some cherries as a gift
ooh a complimentary gift bag of cherries
for my cherry gift bag
I I somehow managed to get all of the
all the fruits in the first day yeah I
saw that I don't know how how I lucked
out on that but creams from Denmark
hello ooh oh oh oh there really that's a
fancy boy Wow
I like that that mint suit that's real
nice I really enjoy seeing oh you can't
actually buy them from Timmy and Tommy
but the the complimentary gift bag you
know it's true yeah yeah you could just
bite you if you want you could buy
Cheerios from them but I figured I would
I would give you guys awesome cherries
you gotta love them out of the half-step
and yep at this point equip resigned
ourselves it's just how it's gonna be
for a ha minute yeah it's all good we
got tons of time we're only seven
minutes in ain't no thing
enjoying this game but yeah there's a
minute-long animation introduced people
when they visit yeah
maybe they'll patch that later on or
something because I understand they've
got a like master loading somehow or
something but it's the part where it
stops everybody like that's a thing that
in multiplayer games like normally when
somebody joins a multiplayer game it
doesn't pause everybody you know what I
mean so I kind of appreciate maybe if we
got rid of this flight information
screen even though it announces who it
is this is like on the banner put like
this person from this island is coming
and then just show the part where they
walk in yeah I agree like there's also
weird stuff like I can't be on my phone
when they try and join I'm not sure why
that's a thing it might be like a decent
King thing or something with all these
weird things and weird restrictions
there they have to do
excellent excellent shirt look at that
cat
it breaks if they fly while you're
walking in a door oh my gosh stopping by
to say thanks for the tutorials GameSpot
that really helped me hey excellent yeah
we're doing the best we can and those
people worked really hard on the items
in the chat don't thank us mean Ben
didn't do any of that that is all the
hard hard work of yeah Callie Jake and
then some other people have been helping
edit those David Evan it has been a real
team effort from from everybody to get
this done so Mac well I think max has
also edited a couple of guides so shout
out to everybody who's been doing those
except for me in bed because we have it
yeah I mean I only throw them into the
internet space so people can look at
them and that's that's not even a thing
but mmm yeah you really should be
thanking them you should see the notes
that like Jake and Callie were taking
while they were getting around already
there's like day by day breakdowns of
things that happen throughout the course
of the entire day and it was amazing and
they deserve all the praise you should
give it to them
yeah twenty people are we at this point
that's a good question I haven't been
counting because did you and me Persia
I think we're either at five or six I
think we're at six somewhere around
there
Islands full I think we're still maybe
because you can't join when people are
doing things yeah nice nice I like those
those glasses a lot and that tie-dye
shirt says it says a lot just here to
chill absolutely
heck yeah yep yeah I've just set my
controller down oh that one's weird it
didn't okay hello all right I'm good I'm
able to run around this is wacky yeah
nope there it is
you know I prefer it this way than not
having people show up
oh me too yeah yeah let's get it all the
way now real sad you know also it's
really cool how this game came along at
the time that it did it's it's real
interesting it really is you know I'm
into it
ah I think there's a chance I could
order a switching this game online from
what I hear switch hardware's really
hard to come by now but it's definitely
worth checking out
yeah if you're able to find a switch Oh
Brandon is this you Brandon Oh awesome
heck yeah fantastic
I know that I know on GameSpot we are
Commerce team our deals team has been
scouring the internet looking for any
time there's a switch so I would keep it
on GameSpot because I want to say we've
we've been updating every time we see
like a switch available by online so if
you're interested in trying to find one
definitely check that out
as far as getting the game you might be
better just getting it physically or
digitally getting the game digitally
wants to get a switch yeah everybody got
real quiet no no is my mic thing doing
the thing right to me okay my levels
look okay I'm gonna keep it on that
sounds good
love this I love all this I came with my
camping gear ready
I've got binoculars on we got we got is
is this the is this the full group is
this everyone right now it might be
everybody how do you check
that's just my best friends list if
people can't get in we might have done
it so got got one two three four five
six I'm trying out it up bad bad at
counting okay we're basically just here
to chill hekia yeah I would just full
we're hearing yeah we're all hanging out
in the Times Square or the residence
hall roll we roll why me you you call it
Times Square this could be it could be a
square John this is my time square I
still love that for some reason I can
talk and cry and cry on command
there we go that's that's what I want to
hear just yeah oh this is wonderful
oh we do need a gamespot flag oh yeah I
just got the ability to do flags heck
yeah so they were the original idea we
had for this before everything kind of
mess ups we'd have like like a switch
with just an island that we all worked
on together on it that kind of like to
work out snow now we're just hanging out
in John Luke's place was great yeah okay
I'm not going cite you here I need a
look in here let's see what's happening
here you shirt how does she do me how
does she how does she know me
she said I'm famous you're famous she
said this butterfly hard that was
embarrassing really don't get why this
game is so huge right now so we want to
fill me in on what it is it's it's kind
of like a nice okay if you don't know
what the game is you kind of like build
things up and have like a nice town and
talk to villagers and kind of build out
a house it's got like uh if you ever
played The Sims kind of like that kind
of appeal going for it but just more
more adorable you know it's just really
chill and low-key you know it is and
it's just kind of a nice way to kinda
now you can hang out with people and
have a good time yeah it's relaxing it's
a relaxing video apology is my Island
it's not the most exciting Island I'm
still kind of developing it dude I'm
gonna do it I turn on your your bamboo
shoot' water thing yeah unfortunate I
can't place objects when people are in
my game otherwise I'd like start just
putting stuff out it's fine ah you know
I'm gonna start making bait to go
fishing
that's that's what I'm feeling I I like
to fish in this game
fishings real fun you can help me get
peaches if I could I would oh that fish
come on I should talk to your villagers
I know you had Agnes in here
never forget a name what I got sicker
than a child
hey that's fair if it's not a kind of
game that you're into yeah well good
play what makes you happy
exactly NHL's got some cool stuff going
on you got that that old hit stick
technology that I remember from back
when I played in like 2008 I do feel bad
that I haven't played one in a while do
you have some wildflowers on your Island
no thank you if anyone wants to take any
my flowers I have up on the the upper
levels go for it are you sure my my good
flowers I have barricaded behind the
fence so uh so these are just the extras
on yeah increase Oh apparently you can
get the inventory increase again I can
think so
Oh oh yeah yeah yeah I should crack this
it's linked to getting the upgraded main
building you're totally right I should
check that Bob says it's 8000 points I
think a decent amount of points I have
oh I have 9,000 yeah I could do it dude
do it those big pockets shadow can't
wants to know how you have picket fences
one of the things you do for Tom Nook
gets you one ultimate pocket stuffing or
there you go and then yeah what's he get
picket fence to get fences from Tom Nook
he then every day they rotate between
two different offenses in the
look miles as well so I kept a iron
fence or an Imperial fence yeah you
weren't kidding about these peacock
butterflies they're everywhere
there are literally everywhere get on
them you want some you want make some
money Devore I've already caught two
like I'm here for it I thought I was
gonna fish but it turns out I'm actually
just gonna catch a bunch of bugs Alan
wants to know what your your native
fruit is on your islands your cherries
oh you can't talk to her when you have
people over because she's so busy
dealing with oh she said hi to me at
least I mean I'm in into that Oh as soon
as I can - i'ma start building a lot
more bridges I can't wait to be able to
build like ramps do I got I got nothing
but mats on deck I'm ready to do a thing
the deepest pockets
yeah I hope the stress isn't getting to
Isabel - she just showed up today and
then John looks like we got extreme
Isabel there's so many people who are so
it's a good way to do it Dover's over
here what he won't let me wake him up
well you spin in that shovel first she's
gonna leave to someone else can come and
visit there you go a spots about to open
up and apparently all right hopefully
that's better that sucks because that
means all three of the different methods
I've tried to get this microphone to
work have not worked so I not really
sure what to do now hmm
I almost know of bolting poles can break
they don't break no they're they're
permanent
there we go if you won't take any my
coconuts go for it like I said I think
I've scoured all the cherry trees
already by Persia thanks for coming to
hang out Bob Jones to get a loose wire
power problem yeah so I tried at first I
thought maybe was the XLR cable so I
swapped it wasn't the issue then I
thought it was maybe the mixer input so
I went to a different input still still
having an issue then I thought was the
power I I changed it so that it was on
its own it was it was in its own plug so
it's only getting power from that so
that should be like better and then I
checked the power cable and it seems
like it should be the right cable hmm
I'm like a bit like the voltage seems
like it was there but maybe maybe this
microphone takes up more juice than I
think and I need to get a different
cable I don't know but that's I mean I
think it's a power issue as well but I'm
just not unfortunately sure what what to
do
the microphone is too beefy it's too
beefy out there we go someone's trying I
love it well Brandon says that you're
not your island is really nice oh thank
you
I agree I like I really like going to
just other people's islands and seeing
how they have everything set up I'm
really excited to start messing with it
I want to now that I have the improved
resident services I can start to like
move stuff around so I think I want to
like replan where everything is you know
yeah yeah and I can't everything boys
just a boy yeah I would like to really
like plan all this have my Island
planned out I'm starting a plan like
certain like treaty kind of like patches
for the different fruits I really want
to gather all of my fruit trees together
and put
in one place because right now they're
just spray have you done I've done that
with my oranges so my oranges are all
together keeps going and kicks me out
it's it's cuz you're bumping up against
other people trying to get in so we just
got the the replacement person all the
way from Hyrule all the way from Hyrule
it's really good it's a very good call
I think it's cool you guys are playing
Animal Crossing I think it is - oh we
can do it I love that I was like you're
ready for an adventure that's a door
yeah
wish Animal Crossing was available for
PC yeah
same it'd be it'd be interesting to have
on PCs you think about all the cool
things you can mod in like yeah a wild
time a wild world even oh there's
another one of those butterflies I'm
doing it that's that's my jam right now
oh no I started their basis other spots
opening there's a water drop it in
Brendan yeah thanks for hanging out
appreciate it happy I got a pic with all
you guys on the island I'm happy that
you're able to come hang out to that
sweet home geez offering some fruit
trades if anyone's interested hey if we
all just get together at rate fruits
around that's something I'm down with -
apparently the mic volume is down again
is down again I'm not I'm not hearing at
this time
ah very filling the the spot maybe oh I
think that bug left the butterfly it's
definitely gone
it's just flew away what's with the UH
the spinning is that is that like an
online thing the we're we're the shovel
because he does like the spin now I
think so if it's if it's got like I
think it's gonna like wait a sec up with
or something interesting hi from Ireland
from oh it's it's Rebecca the one with
the cool star glasses hey yeah hello
good so it's a have you here
I hope you're having a wonderful time on
Jim John Luke's island while we wait for
people to go in we're all on this
together really there's gonna be a lot
of Menifee Joe Joe tell masks I like it
I think at some point they definitely
have to adjust this to make it a little
bit shorter I would hope so
[Music]
though the flipping theme the airline
theme music for the edits they really
nail that for it not air like careful
airline vibe from Wisconsin yeah so we
got a lot a lot of cool people from the
Midwest gonna hang out yeah yeah that's
rad
I'm into it did four people from
Wisconsin all just meet each other I
love that that's excellent
there's a shout out to Wisconsin them
like three people followed up saying a
same because if so that's fantastic by
the way if if my islands full and other
people just want to get together I
highly encourage the chat to like form
your own like hangouts as well yeah if
you want to like try to get together and
share some some fruit or trade off some
items you throw your cool I'm literally
grabbing every hole I'm gonna try to
find these butterflies again is I wonder
if it's because you're here flowers you
have or something or there's like like a
thing going on
oh are you giving this to me
I reran and this game did come out at a
perfect time
I was just gifted a helmet I I didn't
want to run past you there your your
fishing I want to scare your fish away
oh he just gifted me the garden helmet
oh yeah
well shoot you can have my outdoor hat
if you want yeah trade there you go yeah
oh that's great I love it I'm gonna head
over here and look for more parts so
dapper
right I'm trying I'm trying to find
these butterflies I'm that I'm
exclusively hunting them that's what I'm
remarried yeah I saw somebody in the
chat just give out there dodo code so if
ours is full go join some other people's
games in the chat yeah we got some some
cool kind of spillover happening Oh bees
everywhere maybe there wasn't a oh right
there nope still not a I whipped it on
both of those you'll feel bad about that
one
I'm just having a good time listen to
this music - to be honest it's a it's a
bob it's kind of weird that you have to
wait so long to get to the our themes
yeah I didn't I was surprised when they
kicked it and this so this is my first
animal Crossing's I wasn't like I'm not
familiar with all the the stuff people
normally know but I was shocked when I
started it up I'm like oh there's
different music now like okay yeah yeah
which means pretty soon we're gonna have
those Animal Crossing ten-hour
compilations of 3:00 a.m. oh heck yeah
set set terrain music yeah sad sound
effects over it that's what I'm here for
it's how you do it alright soon Oh
people join in they're getting their
fruit hookups they need oh you got a
water fountain outside your museum I do
and a place to sit damn it's gonna chill
out right here
hey Gulliver got all your parts close
your nook phone no no no what the Mac
star piece you can get hour per day I
don't know if there's a max on it I
don't know either
I sit there and I farmed it out for like
an hour and a half and I think I got one
for everyone that I wished on so it
being like 25 or something like that
there might be someone else who's on
their phone oh I think that's for the
people in the chat who are starting a
different different Scotia well looks
like we you say might be hanging out
here soon - thanks for hanging out oh
yeah thank you
another open space here in a second
[Music]
my buddy Amelia was asking uh oh it says
that he wished on 2015 only got 35 so
maybe that's not a limitation and I
basically was the game different from my
expectations it's about what I expected
kind of from what I've heard of the game
I think I'm still like it's it's weird
it's one of those things where the game
is like sort of straightforwardly what
it is like it's not like it it suddenly
has like a secret hidden like gameplay
to it it's like very straightforward but
I really like that about it and I'm like
surprised how much do I liked it so like
it's just like wait all you do is like
catch things and build the stuff and
they're like yeah and I'm like all right
okay I'll do that for a hundred hours
this one's pretty good
it's
it's really interesting how this one's
set up so well that I play the most is
the original and I keep kind of going
back and forth thinking about what that
one has and what this one has and
there's a lot of stuff I kind of Miss
that they don't have here but I really
like this one for what it is - mm-hmm
there we go we got someone on the way
taking this spot
all right is it a game we have to grind
for a lot of resources there's one point
where they ask you to get like thirty
pieces of iron and after you get past
that it doesn't seem like it's too bad
yeah they have a lot of limitations on
you like your your equipments kind of
not as strong mm-hmm a lot of people
kind of get hung up on that a little bit
but I already got in Internet trash yeah
you have the police station and the post
office just so that I feel like I feel
like Bruce just gotta show up at some
sir they teased Leif coming up and I'm
really glad that he's gonna be back yeah
just add some of that stuff over time I
mean there's also small stuff like the
the one thing that keeps getting me that
I really misses when you used to start
up the game one of your villagers would
greet you and be like oh hey thanks for
coming back it's good to see you again
let me load up your game for you and
kind of like a small dialogue or when
you quit you'd have a villager come up
and say hey you did a lot of good stuff
today go off and you know get some rest
we'll be waiting for you when you come
back and I got that stuff even though
it's really dumb and small but yeah I
feel like a lot of the missing
characters they might bring back but
yeah I missed the police station and the
Lost and Found stuff oh heck yeah
looking sharp I like it so you consider
time-jumping cheating I think people can
play the game however they want but for
me I don't want to do it
I kind of like taking Animal Crossing
kind of as it happens it's also
interesting this time around because I'm
much more active on like Twitter so I'll
see like everyone talking about how
blathers is making them wait oh yeah man
this kind of kind of sucks but we're all
in it together but then Traverse Li you
see all the people on Twitter who are
like check out my my mansion of a house
with a pool in the back and you're like
you son of a you I I do get envious but
I don't consider it cheating because
it's like I said you can play it however
you want but I it's not for me come on
first animal Crossing's won't mess with
anything I feel like it's good to kind
of take it you know as it happens yeah
that's also part of it for me that I'm
having terrible luck with this fish do
fishing
fishings no joke there we go so serious
thing small yellow perch Sona have an
island I can join I know that we are
Islands full right now and there was
another one kind of getting passed
around the chat a little bit
hmm I love the idea of people just
setting up other islands I will baby
wing out I mean one day we'll get in the
Animal Crossing a battle royale and we
can have a hundred villagers drop onto
someone's Island it'll be it'll be great
the first one to craft a wooden bench
wins there you go yeah you're just
beating each other up so that you can
all farm that rock for iron exactly
like from State Farm I love it
oh wow we've got the honor to have you
oh I missed that beat this is a sick
WebP umbrellas oh no I got a uh I got a
rainbow umbrella yeah I like meeting all
the umbrellas oh this is for me
the dodo cries when we can't fly you
somewhere no yeah the I love that a lot
of the like sound effects are still
there and everything
JP calls out the the wahoo sound when
you catch a fish it's it's real good
people keep dropping off stuff for me I
don't have I wasn't expecting this I
didn't prepare to give other people
things you got gifts I wasn't I wasn't
prepared for this so apparently you can
get tambourines and other musical
instruments in this game
Oh what that's right some still I'm
still rocking the ocarina
The Rock arena would want this game but
I don't even know it intend oh oh come
on it's definitely one of those
situations where I if if I had it if if
I could snap my fingers and make
everyone who wants animal crossing in a
switch our do it it's the same nice
thing I feel bad for anyone you can't
never gone
when I cannot connect to any islands um
as long as your internet stuff is set up
you might not be able to connecting this
one just cuz it's full but just anyone
this one's fall yeah bring Kalia she's
probably busy doing a whole bunch of
other stuff she's got she's got real
work to do while we sit here and play
ocarinas on Venice know how to friend on
Nook phone if you go in you go down to
the best friends lists and let you pick
people but oh I am waiting on approval
from you so I don't think you have to be
friends with them on your friends list
to do it I actually don't know because I
got one from Persia and I don't think I
have her on my friends list on my switch
I think they're separate okay oh that
would be it you need Nintendo online I
think to be able to play oh if you don't
have a Nintendo online
oh yeah that's probably oh you do me oh
yeah you added me like not too long ago
what am I thinking
it's we've been a lot of friend requests
yeah yeah we've we had that whole thing
in the rial shared each other's codes in
the office that's true here's a whole
document let me go back sweet thank you
for for hanging out appreciate it you
have how people just how is it already
been 45 minutes
right dude Zweifel time flies when
you're playing Animal Crossing what else
I love how I get the time reminder in
the game now yeah it looks like you have
to be have a friends list Adam that
makes sense I mean you know you wouldn't
want to be best friends with a person
you're not friends with right that's
there's there's an order to things or
something
thanks for hanging out appreciate it I
guess that's Rebecca that's on the way
out absolu cool haven't yet and also I
might as well do this because if the
streams gonna be over before I even
realized it if you guys do enjoy what
you're experiencing you should
definitely subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss a single show we do
stream every weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific
the show you're watching right now is
community fridays with me and John Luke
where we play video games III have a
second plug you can drop as well Ben Lee
is today is the first official day of
GameSpot's
discord server oh yeah we opened up
access that these people are getting so
if you are interested in we're kind of
slowly letting people in I think at a
time just not to overwhelm it so if you
are interested just hit up me or Ben on
Twitter and we'll we'll hook you up
you send you an invite exclusive access
to these people in the stream
we got new people coming in so you gotta
kind of keep an eye on when people leave
and and and all that you can try to jump
back in but we've already got someone
stepping in for the for Rebecca who just
left I do like that we have people who
are likely lined up and ready to go
though hello how are you this Friday's
game looks really fun can't wait to get
my own was your first animal crossing
game mine was new leaf it's one of my
favorite games says Krystal in the chat
my first animal crossing was the first
one on GameCube and it's it's still kind
of like Det
deep down kind of my favorite but I feel
like this one has a good shot once I
play more of it to be up there but
really like new leaf - and mm-hmm
city folk was all right but not my
favorite yeah yeah I like the series a
whole bunch and I'm glad that you're
here
and my friend is going well oh nice
like the look look good like a jet set
radio character oh yeah yeah yeah I'm
into it yam is my first animal crossing'
was this one so this is my first my
first experience I'm having a very good
time with it oh shoot TV brings up a
good point it doesn't have Twitter so
how's he gonna play Shadowrun now oh um
hmm what's a good way for him to hit us
up
I'll have to think about it how's my my
game just decided to freeze Oh No
yes I'm stuck on this bench and you
can't leave oh that's that might be Oh
someone quietly left that's what they
didn't want to they didn't want to make
a big big fuss um I'm sure at some point
will will it'll just get tweeted out
right probably I would have seen without
me
or maybe able to get maybe we'll post
about it on the website maybe we'll be
able to put it in the description for
the YouTube videos at some point yeah
I'm sure it at some point in time it'll
it'll come across as a thing that's more
easy to access but yeah we're trying to
slowly roll it out exactly accidentally
turn off my switch oh no that would that
would do it also I hope that it does
don't get any save errors or anything
somebody went home we'll go back to my
bench play my ocarina again
someone else is leaving we got some some
spots I think yeah can't wait we got a
couple spots now a communication error
although this stuff might have thrown
some people off well will even out
everything will be okay am I supposed to
be picking up flowers or leaving them
blooming I I'm not 100% sure what the
best strategy for flowers is so you can
pick them if you want to and you could
like put them in your hair is like an
accessory and that kind of thing but if
you have the the two flowers bloomed you
can actually crossbreed them by having
them next to each other and watering
them that's as far as I know I'm not
really up on it but if you crossbreed
them you can get special new like for
like a species of the flower and
different flowers will attract different
insects and butterflies which what else
is out of the way it's there's a lot to
flowers I think there might actually be
a guide at some point coming through for
them so you should definitely yeah an
eye out that if you wanna know more
about flowers I'm not the best person
ask as I most of my knowledge is from
the first game and it's definitely
update Callie is working on a flower
guide I believe so look forward to that
for all your hot flower tips so somebody
turn the new phone on it's an airplane
mode always happens that's fair
so everyone just really excited
nerdy I'm sorry the communication errors
are no good yeah sigh people are having
so many weird communication errors I'm
so stoked and surprised so many people
are getting into so actually get in you
know whoa look at that is a look
those those gold shutter shades are
that's one of the things I think I've
done the most envious on this whole time
I'm playing there seen someone coming
with something that's darn impressive we
got someone else coming in to fill in
another spot I think immediately I think
we're good yeah I think I think we're
good
hello once someone's on the way I think
or some someone might have I got
disconnected again yeah no I know
forgot some some rough rough turbulence
happening LaVon the village is worth
stuff I give them yeah it's really nice
because you get so you get so kind of
give them a thing and they're usually
pretty happy about it
I like going to visit them when they're
setting up their house cuz they're
almost always crafting something and
they almost always end up giving you a
DIY recipe for something too I hope it
wasn't an animal crossing plane crash
that's no good it's deserted on that
tarantula island so I know it's on the
way
oh my god there's no room on the dock
[Laughter]
okay well we're just gonna be here for a
hot minute that's fine this is good with
that ever gets to show off through the
characters yeah good uh what are the
games you play on your channel anything
anything and everything but like I said
earlier the show that you're watching
now is a show or chawl no can i usually
play games with you guys so right now
we're playing Animal Crossing cuz it's a
new game that came out a week ago and
it's kind of a nice relaxed time yeah
for last week we played doom with you
guys just whatever whatever you want us
to play we'll probably end up playing it
as long as it's not against Terms of
Service sharp on YouTube that's kind of
the only big
I got dripped show off what's the dodo
coat I love it the dodo coat is it's so
underneath your camera right mm-hmm yep
ah the frog shirt that's a good shirt
looking good
do you like Pokemon yes pokemons a good
time not as good as a lot of other
people but you got I got that love for
those Pokemon in my heart somebody asked
easiest way to make money we actually
have a guide for that we do it's trigger
so go check that out if that's what
you're looking for
Catherine it'd be a good time we should
do competitive Catherine at some point
oh yeah I wanted to do that I think the
timing and I just didn't work out on
that game was coming out and so it's
coming on
I'm switch I can do that do like a whole
GameSpot office wide tournament stream
it let the people know when's the
discord link dropping that's a good
question like I said for the moment we
are not trying to flood it so I don't
think we're gonna just like drop it
right in here but we if you do want in
and you have Twitter just hit me and Ben
up on Twitter we'll hook you up but yeah
but we just don't want to throw it in
right away it's the first day we're
trying to we're trying to keep it a
little more contained oh man it's a
connor from Assassin's Creed 3 here I
love it
so them to invest in competitive Kathryn
big same here we go I'm just gonna put
my controller down for a bit it's gonna
put weight I'm able to move your mind no
we're okay for a minute cool well nope
nevermind you've done it it's okay cuz
eventually we're gonna get everyone full
it's gonna be full and we'll be able to
run around who are you looking for a
Twitter you're looking for either me
that's at John Luke's IP or been at van
genka that's probably the easier one to
spell are getting these outfits I just
bought the game uh you can check your
nook shop to get things shipped out to
you a day later sometimes they'll have
some cool clothes there a couple of days
in you'll get one of the the able
sisters showing up that Mabel and will
show up and she'll sell you some clothes
you can get them from balloons yeah
actually got a lot of mine from balloons
this is the Animal Crossing Airport hub
stream Mesa going hope you guys really
like this loading screen just gonna say
we're all just enjoying this kind of
like airline mmm - well people come in
it's good stuff
I think I think we'll be full after this
one I think we'll be in yeah I think
we'll be full for a hot minute
bumper
doot-doot-doot also I love that the
airline is run by todos oh yeah it's so
good this really it's perfect
drinking a beer and playing Animal
Crossing with you guys can't complain
that is a excellent Friday
there's V set up is I know that shirt I
know that man is that the UH hide your
kids hide your wives guys I think it's
the the shirt that's got that something
that I need
oh maybe okay forget his name but he
doesn't wear a shirt and boy does he
know how to dance
Ricardo that's it okay okay we were yeah
we weren't full yet this has got to be
the last person that will be full the
fielded how to spell your last name uh
its Kara's just putting the Twitter Oh
first got everything there you go and
Ben I believe you should have the
ability to send yeah I think a invites
out the mistakenly caught papa
it's Egon from Rosa Creek
Oh star voice-chat whoa that's a spicy
voice chat I can't join it's because
we've got people you can't join while
someone else is joining mm-hmm and we
might be full maybe it there's been so
many people coming in and leaving we've
been staring at the screen for a while
really just well acquainted with it it
really appreciate all the little details
it's true they managed to buy an antenna
online heck yeah I if you're able to I
highly recommend doing like the family
account I don't remember the limit but
it's like it's like 21 a year and then
I'm splitting it between me and my
girlfriend my brother and so like we're
only each paying seven dollars a year
which is really good so and I forget how
many people you can do a family account
with but if you if you've got a couple
of friends or some family members who
own switches and you want to split up a
a Nintendo switch online subscription so
way to do it the family account there
you go dude this is a fun stream to
watch I may not have gotten on the
island but they did eat pizza and that's
pretty great too heck yeah I'm extremely
jealous of the fact that you have a
pizza that you've been able to eat maybe
maybe I'll get a pizza for dinner in a
couple hours
it sounds like a really good plan to me
I do believe that lemon has eight people
and I think we may have hit it I think
we hit it again
Mavericks got a gift for you
Oh Frank you down sure I wasn't
expecting all these gifts tried joining
soon I just have to keep an eye on when
someone leaves and then we'll know if
it's if it's open or not that's not
really good outfit by the way
well I should think I should show off my
some of my outfits I have oh heck yeah
we're still a fashion show in the middle
of the the town square what though let
the people know so if I do
so I got my MyLink shirt I'll definitely
come back next one heck yeah oh heck
yeah no I really appreciate I hope you
have a good rest of your day and your
weekend look forward to seeing you
yes I got this uh winwaker link shirt
which is pretty cute very appropriate to
be wearing on this island heck yeah
and then I also have for all you persona
fans out there I have a outfit who is
these oh my gosh
gifts getting thrown around you've got
I've got do I take everything does it
should I feel like we shouldn't split
them got a Gintama outfit cuz of course
I do that's that's excellent
well so I got the most important one ah
Miku I got my Miku outfit got my 69th
Hokage what that's great
his RPG shirt from resonable - this one
might be a little risque but you know
when you got a we got dressed up like a
killer kill you can oh yeah yeah I had
as soon as I saw those I had to download
them for Syd of course I gotta also be I
love everyone right now it's just
showing off all their different outfits
they have yeah the best one though put
oh it's okay maverick put a cat on on a
shirt
Oh Thank You searing oh that actually
matches my Chi outfit very well crystal
says they love percent and the Chia
sweater there is a great link that has
just a ton of all the different like
persona characters for outfits very good
what is this goose villager back here a
big top what of what a big top school I
like big top sure he looks like he's
ready to get shot out of a cannon I love
his Ackley
ah why does he call me a villain that's
just his nickname he gives people it's
what he calls me to Big Top what's the
deal man geez you know John Luke from
this island he's got a title it's really
cool the title is unpossible trash you
can't get rid of them oh yeah this is my
current title is untouchable trash oh
shoot I like it when folks call me
shrimp tempura master your Big Top gets
me Big Top is good you never let them
leave go ahead my house for a second
caps and stuff oh yeah I don't think
I've actually even seen your house so
bad I I'm not I haven't fully figured it
out yet yeah any sort of progress is
good progress Oh a cute little mouse it
tells me to eat it oh man there we go
coming in can I add my house so the this
carpet I have it's an earth rug and at
first when I got it I was like oh it's
like a rug with like an earthy tone to
it you know like a
it's like a literal earth globe this
rust fantastic I love it
yes maverick also I really really like
you sure that is quite excellent
it's really good that's a really good
term manager yeah yeah I got this really
good a skull a wallpaper oh heck yeah I
even didn't realize it was skulls see
unfold the island is full right now the
island is indeed fall someone leaves
you'll know cuz we gotta watch the whole
thing when they leave well aware yeah
Bobo serves on the back oh that's cute
oh oh yeah that's that's the stuff I'm
here for see O'Shea had anything cooler
to like to show off but that's that's
kind of it that's the extent now still
figuring out I mean I got a lot of
things that I unfortunately I guess I
can't like take them out now probably
but I have like this
Roback skull radio which is pretty cool
yeah a little like ink cartoonists at a
couple of different blenders Oh
apparently your your foster collection
is impressive oh yeah I actually haven't
gone and looked at that in a hot minute
I'm you know we should do a museum
run-through let's do a museum
run-through someone have a chrono
PayPal's for it this wait to get a crown
may be offered
I don't know I don't know where the
crown pops up but Wendy get the ladder
so you get the ladder when Tom Nook asks
you to build a couple more houses for
people and he then gives you the ability
to craft a ladder okay where should we
start should we start with the fish the
bugs or the fossils oh you start from
maybe the left and then go go up and
then to the right okay I like I like the
aquarium a lot more than the other thing
this personally but I was like how they
they kind of like mix the exhibits
together like even though we're going
into the bug one they've got like fish
yeah swimming around the museum's just
really chill and I appreciate that about
it if this were a real museum I would
spend hours oh just kind of walk around
seeing stuff there's B there's a B
couple different bugs you got a wasp up
there already that's good uh I'll be
enough I actually haven't gotten stung
yet really you do get you do get a Nuke
mile for getting stung so you should do
that I got yeah I got uh I got caught by
a tarantula but I haven't gotten stung
yet
so I should probably I should probably
go out and get stung at some point oh
this one I got some stuff pill bug and a
centipede and a moth in a can and a cat
there the can is is real good it's my
favorite bug oh you got some like
butterflies popping out over here Jenny
your W weapons experiments are you doing
over here in the back yeah the museum is
just so detailed does anyone have a
cutting board and I unfortunately do not
have a cutting board they've actually
actually need to get one oh this is
Eurasian yeah I got all these different
butterflies yeah this is really nice I
like it a lot
oh you can sit right there heck yeah
I'll get that I don't take a photo these
these gosh-darn butterflies floating
around like I just I want to catch a
shark too via the or Fisher I don't I
haven't got an oarfish yet I keep trying
to get one and there's no luck there
like a jump scares some of those basket
check outfits red Thank You gray fox the
mica outfit is rad it's one of the old
ones I had from new leaf today I want to
make sure they're still had cuz you know
I gotta keep that amiko on me I really
appreciate the the fact that they let
that stuff from new leaf cross over yeah
you're doing we doin fossils next and
now I'm doing fish coats Queen fruit
screen for ten minutes
oh no and fortunately it's currently
full right now can no one no one's left
yeah
so if someone feels like they had they
want to to let other people in for the
the last 20 minutes of the stream be
cool no no no pressure though I mean do
you think
I really like the music in the museum
too it's just real chill chill vibes
here we go
is this game seriously that good or
interesting yeah I like it it gives you
kind of a cool cool thing to do just get
to kind of make stuff and hang out with
friends and have a fun fun time yeah I
mean obviously it's not for everyone if
it doesn't look like it's something that
appealed to you you probably not tuned
too into it I hear and see if it looks
even a little bit fun though you're
probably gonna have a good time yeah
yeah that fish is is disgusting
I do like that you can kind of like sit
back here and look through the portholes
oh yeah all right they go someone's
leaving so if anyone else has been
trying to get in that's your chance
never heard of it but it looks calming
yeah I think this might be like the
maybe like the biggest thanks for
hanging out Ian
thank you and this might be may be well
it is definitely the biggest release for
this series mm-hmm
first there are a lot of people who are
able to play it for the first time so
it's understandable to the mad scramble
to join I'm feeling it i I can feel
everyone already mashing away through
their a buttons
so point new leaf I I've kind of fallen
off of it a bit but mm-hmm
I have good memories a new leaf it was
it was kind of like the perfect way to
play a portable and got touchscreen
controls and was a good time I I meant
to get into new leaf and then by the
they it was like they had just announced
animal crossing or like they were about
to and I was like well I guess I should
wait it was still like a good felt like
what year and a half two years before it
actually came out so like I honestly
could have gotten into the movie it's
just kind of I don't know yeah so it was
on the way who's it gonna be so it's a
PC game out of mobile game no it's a
it's a game on on the switch it's a it's
a Nintendo deal I mean it's it's it's
big like it's you got two characters in
it or too fast two characters from it in
Smash Brothers and all of that
I'm Clear Lake its Aiden I like the
basement something or other that's a
it's a very good title
[Music]
chose oculus VR over switch thought I
would check out hey that's that's all
good uh you can't really go wrong with
with an oculus headset - there's a whole
bunch of really cool VR games you can
play
you got half life just came out this
week plays really well on an oculus hey
as long as you're having a good time
that's what matters but I'm glad that
you still came in to check it out so I
like it whenever anyone comes to hang
out with us whoo heck yeah it's just a
good fun time look I hear you're off to
do some cool college stuff with that
sweater the whole end of the stream is
just gonna be people coming and going
and I'm here for it you know yeah you've
made it congratulations
we're all rolling out there in the
museum at the moment Oh butterfly are
there red snapper there that's a good
one these are good yeah let's check out
them dinosaur bones Hank yeah if anyone
needs oranges Marco's offering so you
guys want to share an island code to
show you some fruit trading see
butterfly there it is
is the animal crossing switch worth it I
got it and I feel I feel pretty good
about it it is the new model switch so
it's it's a little bit of a longer
battery life I imagine it's pretty tough
to get one though yeah it's it's really
pretty too though but if you don't have
a switch at all definitely worth it oh
we got another spot opening up all right
if you don't have one definitely worth
it if you already have like an old model
switch maybe if you really love Animal
Crossing and you want to upgrade for
that like a half an hour of extra
battery life but oh okay someone else
leave just wait a couple minutes for
that yeah it's weird to be here oh well
I'm glad you're here in either case did
you do have some some real bone
collections going on here this is like a
like a pickle over here
Oh someone might be leaving and I think
we have someone's got like their phone
up or something maybe I'll just hang it
out look at this yeah this is my first
AC game yeah mine too
heck yeah we got the flip in like
mosquito and amber over there yeah do a
dodo coat yeah go for it if you guys
want to like make islands on the side of
this one that's totally totally good
please do oh yeah my collections coming
along pretty nicely why can't I leave
someone you trapped here forever you
can't ever leave someone someone's
probably like reading something or they
have like a window up it's something
like that you just keep trying maybe
it'll will let you through you do have a
lot of dinosaurs Shalu I'm surprised I
haven't I don't feel like I've gone that
crazy with Dinosaurs but it's this one's
missing its body this one's this one's
completely done yeah this one's that
one's not done but this one's done I
like that State the Stegosaurus or
whatever that's just got like its entire
like like it's cut off right in a line
there we go he was able to go home
thanks for joining us there we go yeah
thanks for hanging out like you're
you're Connor cosplay it's a good good
time
ah all right
which means there's a spot which means
I'm ready for it to to take us away
again we got about another ten minutes
left on the stream yeah Jake says
they're new here hello welcome
I hope you're having a wonderful day
welcome to our stream we're playing
Animal Crossing with all of you
wonderful people or all people can fit
in here yeah it's a it's a good time we
like John they said we've got about 10
minutes left we'll we'll wrap this up
and then send everyone off on their
weekend to have a good time
there it is
who's it gonna be who's joining who's it
gonna be
live animal crossing big same it's very
good a bright place joint State Farm
Island I love it so I first I'm visiting
a channel I'm enjoying it thank you hey
as long as you guys have a good time
that's after the hunters
feel like I won the lotto Krista's able
to join your party hey there are a lot
of people out here trying to get into
this island wondering who your villagers
are who so you've got you've got that
big top guy
I've got Big Top I got the pig girl it
was really cute I have this like Jacques
lion I forget his name and then I have
I'm trimming over the other two I feel
bad that I like don't recall the names
yet oh just think I got back in okay
sick sick I think there'll be more tips
on how to make money easily uh maybe at
some point I learn that I think we've
got that one video but a crazy robot
bird oh I love the crazy robot I want to
get a robot villager I want uh robot
robots my favorite well I'd like to have
them kept but I still like I don't have
Bob the cat I want Bob to can't real bad
I also want snake who's just a bunny
that's dressed up in like a sneaking
suit oh that's excellent
yeah is there at is there name actually
snake yeah the name is actually snake
Wow
all right now back heck yeah welcome
back
toy L says they watch our vids and they
love us so much thanks oh thank you we
appreciate you coming and telling us
that you you enjoy our videos sweet we
all work hard on them and it's nice to
hear that you guys appreciate them
okay loving it spend so much fun getting
my town yeah a town hall on Sunday
coming up I'm excited I should get mine
tomorrow rooster says they love our vids
- heck yes excellent it's so nice for
all the best where's everyone hanging
that's all I'm getting out of here
someone's leaving our spot what do you
think of persona 5r if you're curious
about persona 5r we've got someone who
is still making their way through it and
working on full review but we've got
impressions yeah for the moment and
Michaels like sounds like Michael's
having a good time with yeah and you
could trust that boy that boy loves him
some persona he he has his trajectory
for that was playing through like all
the persona games in a year and then
getting tattoos of like the three main
schools mm-hmm like all at the same time
so yeah you know you're in good hands
when you listen to Michael about persona
you do I'm very excited to play it when
it comes out pulling Animal Crossing
non-stop Hank yes I I ordered a physical
copy I'm hoping arrives not a hundred
percent on that one but that's okay if
it arrives late I I got plenty of time
true a lot a lot of games going on I
mean I might just buy it digitally I
think so I got the clerks addition for
the original persona five feeling pretty
good about that it's oxic how's it goin
hope you're having a good Friday you
know what I just realized
what up my cats sitting behind me this
whole time and is just sleeping and
hasn't come up at all Oh figure photo
hey I'm down Delta
yeah everything where do you where do
you want to take the photo just all meet
at the town hall just to kind of do it
we're all sena though oh they're right
here there you go
this is a gym it's a pop a certified
banger I want the soundtrack it's got
trumpets I'll do a quick photo as well
I'm just gonna stay here and clap make a
clap and we're crossing worth $60 I
think it is for me worth $60 I don't
feel bad about spending the money I did
on it so I was on the way just in time
for the picture oh no all right oh wait
but if it all comes down to what you
personally feel if if this looks like
it's your kind of game you're you're
gonna have a good time with it if a kind
of iffy and wary of it maybe maybe not
but yeah okay I like it it's a good time
you're hyper stay and let him join
they'll give you a whole samurai outfit
I've been able to us Nicholas from
windfall
this music man tomorrow I'm going to my
dad's house my mom bought me Animal
Crossing for a switch hey tomorrow for
the first time so excited I'm excited
for you I'm excited for you to embark on
your Animal Crossing adventure playing a
ton of stardew and looks like another
good recharge game if you like stardew
you're gonna have a great time I'm gonna
say that that matchup is is almost
one-to-one the Venn diagram is almost
overlapping good vibes all around today
yeah it's it's been a really nice stream
up and having a good time
sure we've had like a cool revolving
door of people coming in and out but
that just means we got friends yeah
we've made it down just here and make
this face the whole time well yeah all
right Tommy thanks for hanging out it's
all good we're here the last bits of the
stream anyway we're closing up getting a
cool picture with everyone here yeah I
love it
crew on deck so any more space I think I
think we might be full
we might be tall and we're about to
close out we got more friends yeah I
think I think this is this is the whole
the whole room that's it
that's everybody everyone's here looking
good dresses sharp
oh thank thank you guys thank you it
means a lot that you chose to hang out
with us on your Friday kind of poke
around an animal crossing a bit yeah
it's it's really nice I'm just taking a
bunch of different photos heck yeah
see a Brandon thanks for hanging out and
even coming onto the island so it's good
to see ya alright well I think that's
about it for this dream time to close it
on down thank you everybody for hanging
out we really appreciate it
hope you have a wonderful wonderful
Friday and a wonderful weekend and we
will see you all on Monday for our usual
usual streams anything else you want to
say Ben don't be a fool stay in school
play yock yock cousin play danganronpa
play Animal Crossing would be nice to
everyone and have a good weekend all
right bye hi clap there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]